did you have any rough times I'm sure of
course everybody has rough times but you
guys were in love until the end right
until the end yeah and that probably hit
you like a brick yeah I mean
suddenly I was doing The Frighteners
when he had the heart attack and so I
flew back
they did his angioplasty he came through
it he was going home the next day he
said honey you've got to fly back
they're holding filming for you
I'm fine so I did four days later he got
got up a blood clot hit his heart and
and he died and my little girl found him
Gabrielle found him
so I flew back to do his service
and then I picked up my kid and my nanny
and flew I was back you know it's
halfway across the world
Australia or New Zealand oh yeah and I
was back and forth four times in two and
a half weeks I didn't know whether I was
coming or going how did how did you even
they had figured out how to shoot around
me and shoot from my back and would you
break down out of the blue
constantly was a constant like you
couldn't handle your emotions you know
yeah I I know now I
I was taught by my mother
watching how she handled all the stuff
with my father
you know I mean he he tried to commit
himself twice so I tried to kill himself
twice and finally succeeded behind a bar
when I was a
senior in high school
and
she was so strong
and she just taught me
you handle it you handle what you handle
and you get through what you have to get
through
so I got back there
and
I I went to the set I had to shoot the
scene
where
uh Michael J fox
or I drop dead and we go Through the
Wormhole yep
and I watched Michael I watched Michael
and before he hit the floor he be he
turned into Chris
wow and
afterwards
the producer came to me and she said Dee
I want you to go see
my doctor so that she can make sure
you know that you're
emotionally okay
and I walked in and this lady looked at
me and she said oh my God
you know they're very into alternative
medicine and
she said you have no life force
at all
I can't even work on you
until I work on your life force
and this is
I had already been kind of veering into
The Healing Arts
but this she laid me down on a table and
she put gemstones on all my chakras
and I thought it was pretty weird I know
yeah
I'm telling you in a half an hour I felt
like I was Reborn
and then she gave me some homeopathic
medicine and she there was somebody on
the set that was supposed to give me
three every three hours or whatever it
was
and everybody you know
just rallied around me and got me
through that took care of my daughter
she was only seven years old
and
I remember
um she was there when I was practicing
flying in the you know in the harness
and she said oh Mommy I want to fly like
Peter Pan and they made her a little
harness so she could go up in it Michael
would play Foursquare with her
oh my and and so at the end of the
brighteners
because they just you know this was for
business class flights back and forth
into and a half weeks
and they said don't worry D we'll take
care of it you can settle up at the end
of the movie well it would have been
more
I think than my whole salary and I went
in to pay it off and
oh sorry no the bookkeeper looked at me
and she said this is Peter's gift to you
he's just gonna absorb all of this and
that's the kind of guy
Peter Jackson are you kidding me yeah